hang on a second there gang before we
get the show started the keep it moving
2021 tour
is in full swing as you know yeah we
have some additions sure
we have some announcements kippy
straighten them out
guys we're coming to providence rhode
island august 11th uh we're going to be
in boston massachusetts august 12th
shaolin new brunswick new jersey august
25th
jersey stress factory we're going to be
in timonium maryland outside baltimore
at magooby's
uh-oh on august 26th then the big thing
moon tower comedy look out we're gonna
be there
at the fest at the fest couple of festy
boys
uh that's gonna be at the end of
september on september 23rd 24th 25th
also another big announcement we're
going to be at skank fest
houston uh that's going to be november
5th 6th 7th plus we're going to be
adding more dates
it's going to be bonkos get some tickets
it's going to be a good time can't wait
to see you there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is
r u garbage sure is it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
we find that if they grow up to be
classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host holy coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antoni's basement
yeah she's upstairs sleeping one off i
don't know what happened last night but
there's a lot of four loco cans
up there i don't know looks like she's
collecting them hanging out with the
kids again
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me unamused as usual he's the
ceo of ru garbage he's an international
businessman
he's kind of the head bozo around here
so show the guy a little respect
give it up for kevin james ryan hey gang
happy to be here as always please make
sure you subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true the roof
those numbers are [ __ ] cooking baby
and then patreon.com you can sign up you
get a [ __ ] ton of bonus content every
month
every week you get ayg you can get hard
feelings which is another whole another
epi uh podcast with me and foley
and then we do live streams with the top
tier patrons every month it's a good
[ __ ] time and also check out check us
out on the road we'll be all over the
[ __ ] joint oh baby we love it how
about a nice shout out to our producer
extraordinaire he's the magic man he
makes us all look good
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen everybody what's up dudes what
up t-bone good to see you buddy but gang
we're on pins and needles here we could
not be more excited to have our
incredibly
special guest here with us for the first
time today
she is an emmy-nominated emmy
award-winning
sports television host she's an a credit
member
of the media i mean all right he's from
a little town called boston
massachusetts
if he ever heard of it but the big
question about his mind today is she
garbage i can say
she is the first guest that ever took
the offer of taking a red bull yeah so
that's not a good sign she's used to
these big corporations
we don't have a slush fund okay katie
nolan everybody
come on hi thanks so much for coming
thank you for having me it's the first
time i've done a podcast in person
in a year and a half so i'm feeling
very close to you in a way we haven't
wiped anything down in two years
none of us are vaccinated we bought all
this stuff for muhammad actually
it was weird i had to kiss you guys to
get in here but
happy to be here yeah uh buddy thank you
so much for coming in man we were
looking forward to this we're excited
what is the uh what's the origin story
of katie nolan i know you're from boston
framingham framingham framingham which
is like 25 i just did it 25 minutes from
the city
so it's you know it's a suburb but it's
still basically it's all kooky up there
it's all little towns
yeah well so we were the biggest town in
the country is what we used to say in
framingham but now we're a city
the biggest town in the city hold on
every every
[Music]
every loser town around the country has
their own we have more bars per capita
we're the biggest this is that
anywhere is that an assignment it's
definitely the thing you say
around town you'd heard somebody say it
welcome to framingham it's
probably on the internet somewhere sure
but we were a big town now we're just
one of the other cities because they
made it a city a couple years ago wow
moving on
yeah i mean i guess that's what makes a
town a city it's a good question that i
should know
but i left that place in the rear view
two chick-fil-as in the cvs
you get the permit there's a mayor now
that's all i know
my mom didn't run for it thank god
no but in her head i thought maybe she
would go for it but um
she's still the unofficial mayor anyway
that's a pretty good question has
any of your family member ever run for
local office yeah oh thank you i got
someone running right now actually i'm
going to the fundraiser this weekend
what's it for it's down in north
wildwood
north wildwood it's a very uh casino
yes it's not a great town basically one
big one in south jersey it's a tough
it's a and you're still allowed to do a
podcast even with a relative running i
feel like they shut
everything down sure well i mean it's
actually a very
i don't yeah i don't even want to cry
it's it's okay to commit suicide tonight
nacelle
she's running for judge nice that's a
little bit
different yeah yeah yeah yeah i didn't
know i didn't know you ran for that
yeah i didn't know you ran for that
either superior court whoa
really no idea she's smart i'm not
saying that because we're going to need
somebody else
in trouble for saying i don't know i'm
sure she doesn't want to be [ __ ]
associated with me
well too late are we making a donation
we could we can make it
sizable cash small bills
go old school all right so you grew up
there so was it
pretty much like a suburban back
suburban
lifestyle yeah it was uh it was a big a
really big town
one of the biggest the biggest as big as
of a town as you can get before it's a
city actually it seems like there wasn't
much else going on
i mean we had a we had a shopping center
there was a mall but that wasn't
it oh that is a big town the mall was in
natick
uh my high school like two thousand a
little more than two thousand that's not
that's a big scary size biggest town
i wasn't kidding uh so that was really
big um
i moved out i went to school on long
island
long island new york college hofstra
yeah hofstra
high school was regular though high
school was uh public high school my
brother went to private school
there's always a reason why he was
really good at hockey and i didn't
really bring much
to the table i was sort of actually
really came out on hawkeye
he was really good at hockey yeah
i don't know that's alleged have you
taken since you're like a professional
broadcaster not just to bozos like us
have you taken like uh get rid of your
accent classes
no i never had it my mom uh my mom grew
up in newton so did my dad
newton they both have them my mom's is
really thick and she was like you will
not
have not you just hit not right there
you just keep talking about this accent
yeah so i've tried really hard but i
still say apparently i say some words
funny that people say is boston like i
guess i say
i sometimes say a boot but that's canada
i know like what do you talk in a boot
but it doesn't
sound that way when i say it but then
afterwards someone is like you just said
a boot and i'm like i didn't
notice and i say parents funny parents
that's i don't know well we're from
philly we say a lot of yeah you guys
sound like cartoon character i know it's
so funny and
the more we the more for the longer
we've been because i got rid of mine
i came up when i moved up here i'm like
i don't want to sound like everybody
else in my house
finishing school
and i i tried to get rid of it but the
more it's just the more we do this show
it just comes out even more yeah the red
bull brings it out yeah that's the
sugar-free ripple yeah
it really hits yeah it gets me all
hopped up uh what what else single
family home
yeah nice yeah and how far apart is your
brother from you
uh my brother is three years older than
he's three years older than you so he
went to private school
yeah cause it was gonna be good for
hockey did you get a scholarship i think
so really what'd your pops do uh my dad
worked at still does work out he's been
in the same job my whole life he works
at raytheon but he's an accountant
what's raytheon that's like it's or or
whip
weapons yeah it's like halliburton
really i couldn't go
iron man works bring your daughter to
work day never happened i wasn't allowed
i didn't couldn't get go
you didn't have clearance to go to my
dad's office i can't have you running
around the mortars and stuff
but then he uh he's like a tax he does
people's taxes
out of the basement okay i'll go on the
side i don't know is that illegal if
it's not
i don't know we're gonna have to dump
this all out i know uh yeah he's just an
he's a nerd but he's been at the same
job my whole life it's
i don't know so he works there at this
big company but then also does taxes on
the side out of your house
yeah this sounds like a cover-up maybe
this is the beginning of a superhero
movie
right but he like we had to finish the
basement so that he would have an office
he's got like a separate door cause it's
one of those basements that isn't fully
underground i've never really understood
split level yeah and so he would you
know clients come in and go to the
oh this is chaseman
and home office separate entrance yeah
come on she went through a couple
therapists like oh gosh
or an orthodontist
i remember i remember one time we parked
in this driveway and then as like well
i was my mom was like in in the waiting
room or whatever and they were like you
gotta move your car we gotta take the
kids
she had to move her car at the orthodox
out of the driveway to let the mom out
you just pull right into the office
put your own chair back did you play
sports in high school i played softball
okay uh and i was the captain of the
dance team ooh
all right thanks guys thank you yeah
like modern dead jet or like ballet oh
it was like we were basically
cheerleaders who didn't flip or lift
each other
oh yeah so like or physically yeah so we
had like pom-poms
okay we did kick line do i have to talk
about anything
hold on so you're you're talking about
that half time
where were you during the game they sit
on the side right yeah behind the
scenes behind the regular channel you
never go to a you ever go to there's a
game you go
had to be some resentment there between
the regular squad and you guys
no because they were they were good they
were like the high school they had
representation
we didn't like i never saw anybody in a
movie that was like i'm on the dance
team
yeah and if they were it was like a
cultural dance team and that was cool
bars
was just us yeah a couple of girls doing
a macarena
it was like when there's when there's
ice dancing at the olympics and you're
like why would i watch this when i could
watch figures yes there's just so much
more to
i did a lot of that in my life now that
i think about it because i also was a
rhythmic gymnast
which is that with the ribbon oh god
that's the least classy of all i have
a junior olympic gold medal that's right
i saw that she has a junior olympic gold
medal
in that uh-huh yeah toby get up
let's see some [ __ ] i want to see
some [ __ ] pizzazz going
it's so funny because it was my whole
life then like my weekends were devoted
to because nobody does rhythmic
gymnastics so you have to drive to rocky
hill connecticut
and have these meets and uh it was like
my whole life
how do you get into that feeling yeah
it's just you and a bunch of
homeschoolers
yeah pretty much it was like in dance
in i was probably five and the the head
of the studio
was like we're going to start this thing
called rhythmic gymnastics we're going
to put together a team and we want your
daughter to be a part of it and so i was
like okay
so your parents were rhythmic dance
parents they would drive you around
my mom yeah i guess my dad did too my
you know kevin my brother was in
hawk hawk cookie yeah and so
there was the over correction it was
great we were the family that didn't
ever go on vacation but that's because
we had
our we spent all of our weekends to do
i like that though my one cousin's doing
that now his whole family's down the
shore for the summer
yeah but he's staying up here he's in
high school he's staying up here while
his mom works
because he's getting ready for a
football camp yeah i like that when you
got something to do yeah something to
focus keeps you out of trouble i guess
yes
i mean rhythmic dance kids when they're
not when they're not performing they're
hell raised yeah i hear they really let
loose
we had rehearsals on saturday mornings
and so i never growing up got to watch
saturday morning cartoons and i like
held
i was very upset about that for a long
time and now i look back at it it's like
it doesn't really matter but it that
sucks as a kid
that's like tanya harding [ __ ] right
yeah it was tough i've had it really
rough
how old are you on the road for the
rhythmic dance tour how old were you
when you won the
gold medal it was 1997 so i was
10. wow 10 years old in your olympics
yeah i don't i look back at it i'm like
were those really the junior olympics
multiple juniors just in someone's
backyard some guy named junior's
olympics
all you have to do to have a rhythmic
gymnastics competition is be like i'm
having a rhythmic gymnastics competition
no one's gonna i don't know that there's
a couple of wrestling mats in there yeah
do you still have the metal
you got to have the medal i did and i
used to put it on set because whenever
you
uh you know it's a weird sentence but
when you get a tv show they're like how
do you want to decorate the background
behind you
yeah so i did and then uh that show got
cancelled and uh they
never i don't think i have it anymore
what really it just faded into the set
of like fake
books that they had back there it's in a
box somewhere i just don't know that we
gotta get it we gotta get to the bottom
of that some grip has that in his uh
dynamite it's not real gold i'll tell
you right
it's not no it was uh it was full of
chocolate
it was i wish it was less usually yeah
it was just gold
colored the gold olympic medals they're
real gold right i think so
i would presume i don't think you're
getting [ __ ] fake gold at the
olympics
it might just be the outside though it
could be like gold-plated yeah i don't
know
get out of here with that that's why
that's why i never tried to be in the
olympics yeah that's why it wasn't for
me
right i want full gold i want full gold
or nothing
what about your mom what'd she do she
was a bartender
really local uh yeah she worked at a
place in south borough called owen
o'leary's
for the first 16 or 18 years of my life
i worked there with her
why i was a waitress she was a bartender
i had to call her cammy at work she
didn't like when i called her mom you
had oh
[ __ ] she was the greatest she was the
greatest bartender
that ain't the i don't that that ain't
the classiest professional no it's not
you would think with your dad's position
in this major corporation
yeah that it would leak down would she
work like like at like at night yeah so
my dad rolled in at like three in the
morning my dad would go
to work during the day my mom was at
home and then my mom would go to work at
night my dad would come home so like
she did it because she used to be a
speech pathologist she went to school
for that and then she was like oh if i'm
gonna have kids i can't we can't both
work during the day
so she just decided to be a bartender
what a left turn from speed pathologist
it's not [ __ ] it's not that far off
really yeah
there's a lot of skills that transfer
trying to understand drunk people what
kind of bar are we talking about an
awesome one uh the upstairs
was a pool it's not like a dive bar it
it's an irish pub
right yeah it was your food it was yep
pretty good food they had these chicken
fingers
really good chicken fingers and honey
mustard which if you're the kid of a
bartender
you're like you just spent all your time
at the bar and i would just always get
chicken fingers
and they also had a sandwich listen i
spent a lot of time eating chicken
fingers and my but my parents didn't
work at a bar so
fair uh there was a sandwich named after
a local radio host
that's the kind of bar that it was the
big louie
i think it was like the 83.2 of the beat
it was
shout out to lauren and wally from i
don't remember 105 7.
either way it was named after one of
them it was like chicken sandwich
wow did they do brunch yes
they did they had a natick location
that's a town over from me that did
brunch
that was like a all-you-can-eat buffet
brunch that was awesome
i don't know that the one my mom worked
at did brunch were there pictures of
local celebrities on the walls oh
probably yeah was there a lot of like
tchotchkes on the walls like a hockey
stick
a glove what about a golden golden tea
arcade was there something anything like
that or yeah
upstairs upstairs there was like a game
room i don't think there was a buck
hunter when i was there there might be
now
i can smell that place right now but
it's not even the worst i mean after
that she worked at a place that um was
in an office building so you'd have to
go into what looked like an office like
this
but not in a city we're in a bridge
we're in a basement i don't know what
you're talking yeah sorry
sorry sorry delete it
i'll i won't move for continuity and
then just splice it in
and we're back okay she's a pro i gotta
give her that
but you would you'd park and it looked
like my orthodontist not to make the
same reference
but you would go in this office thing
and then the office on the right one of
the doors you'd open it it was a bar
was your signs outside yeah and you had
to the bathroom was in the office
building
so your mom worked at an illegal casino
yeah run by tony soprano and his group
now that i think about it holy [ __ ] uh
my mom was the coolest
my mom was so good at bartending she
could have a conversation with anybody
that's where i was like i want to be
like her
yeah that's good cash too that's cash
every day she always had the cash that's
what it is
now she's retired i got people in my
family the same thing that just you know
bartenders and wait and it's just like
you can't walk away from the kids it's
so hard you know you're making like 400
bucks a night in cash
can't do that anywhere else would she
bring home uh stuff from the bar
because that would be we would uh always
have
the best costumes not for halloween but
for st patrick's day
because all the like liquor companies
would send
like glasses fingerless gloves that say
rolling rock
striped hats like cat in the hat that
say bud light on them are you showing up
to school wearing these
on on st patrick's day oh my god she
would deck me out with like the
mardi gras beads that were shaped like
shamrocks
yeah so me not having a drinking problem
is like a miracle because i grew up
with it well that's why i asked you like
was your mom like working late and stuff
like that yeah she would come home at
like two i used to
she had one or two before she came home
or no she really doesn't drink
she smokes weed okay is that cool to say
yeah guys acted like cops when i said it
i just wasn't expecting it to be honest
with you hey me neither i mean
it happened when i was in college you
got a gold medal and an emmy i wasn't
expecting that coming out yeah
you know you can be a good productive
member of society no she used to go to
work
she'd come home around two there was i
would throw parties
god i wanted friends so bad in high
school i would have people over when my
dad would work late during tax season
and my mom would be at the bar i was
like you guys can come over but you got
to leave at like 1
30. sure and i can clean up and then
she'll come home one night that she was
at work
she had to cut a cake and she had the
knife upside down and
pressed down into it sliced her hand
open jesus
and came home because of that and uh
caught me throwing a party which now as
an adult i'm like what
how mad would you be what a shitty kid
you're like i can't work and yeah so
sorry to my mom
any situations that you remember when
you were a kid when your dad got called
to the bar
because somebody was maybe getting out
of line oh no somebody else i don't
think my dad's ever fought anybody in
his life
he pushes a button and blows things
that's what the drones are for my dad
turn your
key my dad's the guy that uh you know
goes to a buffalo wild wings and leaves
with three new friends
okay all right in his mind other people
are like
god we had to talk to that guy for the
whole i could talk to steve again
through the whole email i'll be in touch
yeah exactly
all right as i get older i get that guy
a little bit more yeah when you're
younger you're like
stop dad yeah it's so embarrassing
but as i get older and i started like
every now and then i would go to i'll go
to the bar by myself like after like
whatever
and i'll just like all right i'll just
sit and have a beer
and i'm like now i get straight i get
why people [ __ ] just randomly start
talking at the bar
sure i think i'm not a person that likes
chit chat or small talk or anything like
that
and the only time i i get comfortable in
it and when you do get comfortable in it
you really ride it like i feel like the
the dad in that uh you know turning into
your parents commercial
because if i'm at a like we were in a
bar in chicago at the hotel bar i'm
chatting up to the manager
where are you
[Laughter]
how many ashtrays and pint glasses were
in your house yeah dan came to my house
for one
second time maybe ever this weekend and
um
he was like oh you have the best soda
glasses cause we have those big tall
plastic
they're the best yeah yeah yeah yeah
from a bar yeah that's awesome that was
good and all of our bowls were from
mobile gas station wait i'm sorry what
pull that back
i think this is a common thing it's not
it's not i've heard people say it before
certainly gas stations you know mobile
the gas company i'm aware with
[Laughter]
um like giveaway back in the day i don't
know why
this was a long time ago probably the
80s where they gave away bowls for every
i don't know i don't i do not know yeah
but that we have
all of our bowls for my childhood those
are oil funnels that yeah
[Laughter]
not the best they still have them
probably not we still have my parents
that's what i'm saying your parents like
you go who gets new bowls what do you
need those for you i don't know if
they're multiples or boys
they work do your parents still live in
the same house you grew up in no well
kind of we lived in one until i was in
second grade and then we moved to a new
one and they're still that's where
they're at
okay all right yeah very nice
what both retired no my dad's still
working i think he's going to retire
next year
did you say you can't get a read on her
yeah talking about
gas company balls i know she's got a
[ __ ]
emmy in a [ __ ] gold medal we don't
have that
true i've never even talked to anybody
with an emmy yeah but your forks also
aren't made by slim jim
true yeah but if they were then they're
free and as long as they're good forks
who cares where they came from
damn that's pretty good logic that's
pretty good then the gas station used to
try to get you to buy its gas
hesh trucks yeah come here now it's like
now it's all just give me your money and
leave
exactly so i'm grateful to mobile shout
out wow
kippy kippy kippy what's that caliper
cbd
oh i got news for you what's that uncle
hank's loving it big
fan over there powder form cbd who'da
thunk
unbelievable yeah it's great you know
i'm a big cbd guy
this is fast it's easy it's unbelievable
eases a little stress
helps you fall asleep at night a little
pain a little soreness it's nice
i like the delivery system i love it
likes me all right so this is
keeps me calm big cbd guy as well and
caliper cbd
is powder is the only clinically proven
fast acting cbd i ain't talking slow
acting i'm talking about
fast acting because it's a powder it
delivers 30 times more cbd in the first
30 minutes versus cbd oil i used to be
an oil guy
now a powder board yeah uh get all the
benefits of cbd in just 10 minutes some
cbd oils can take up to an hour to
absorb that ain't the case no more
developed by food and science experts
with decades of experience and tested
for purity and quality
they've done the whole thing uh it comes
in easy to use packs 20 milligrams each
packet
all measured out there's no like i
didn't notice that what the drop shot
like is that one drop two drop how many
drops was that none of that
easy easy always th thc free
feel better without the high no weird
taste residue none of that mix it with
anything any food or drink
uh so guys go to uh trycaliper.com
garbage use promo code garbage you'll
get 20 off your first
order yeah 20 that's lovely we're
talking numbers over love that
uh nothing like a good first order nah
try free for savings
try caliper cbd risk free for 30 days if
you don't love it they'll give you a
full
refund there you go full refund who's
doing that nowadays that's old school
for full refunds
tricalibur.com garbage don't forget
promo code garbage for 20
off your first order the link will be in
the description gang support for all
your garbage is brought to you by our
good friends over there
manscape who is the best below the waist
champions of the world for male grooming
uh
i don't know you tell me it's man's skin
sure is baby we're talking precision
engineered tools to keep it clean
down there on the family jewels yeah
guys they got the new lawnmower
4.0 you heard that 4.0 oh
look out i ain't talking 1.0 2.03 point
i'm talking 4.0
yeah uh saying 3.0 bozos join over 2 and
4.
join over 2 million men worldwide who
have trusted manscape with this
exclusive offer for you
20 off and free worldwide shipping when
you use the promo code garbage
at manscape.com promo code garbage baby
clean as a whistle i was a thing of hums
i was right through bozo back in the day
i used to use a blade and cream like an
idiot but really put really rolling a
dice
sweeney todd a weenie todd
uh guys uh it's fantastic they sent them
to us
i mean you're zipping all over the place
it works in the shower it's quiet got a
light to it got a light on it
so you're not flying blind down there
it's fantastic everything you need
yeah it's and it's it's also like it's
not it takes out all the
stress you can just you're all over the
place you know and let me tell you
something
there's two two lives you live there's
before you started cleaning up down
there
and after you clean it up down there
yeah we're talking fresh
yeah talking it's summer time you don't
wanna you don't want you know you don't
want fur hanging out all over the place
you're running across the chest you know
right by the nips clean that up yeah
trim the yard it's easy peas cut the
grass it's summertime
yeah uh also if you've been using the
trimmer you've been using for your face
on your ball bag
you got to knock that off and get the
get the lawnmower what are we doing
nobody wants pubes in her mouth act like
a gentleman
uh so get 20 off and free shipping with
the code garbage
at manscape.com your balls will thank
you one more time get 20
off and free shipping with promo code
garbage manscape.com
that's 20 off free shipping manscape.com
promo code garbage now back
to the show let's play a little are you
garbage okay
all right we're going to ask you a
series of questions just answer them
truthfully answer them honestly
okay um i don't know you don't you don't
want to say the
the street that you grew up on what was
this what was the name of the street
from the house that you were until
second grade
foster drive that's pretty good that's
pretty good
drives nice nice foster's all right not
bad
what about the name of the grocery store
that your mother shops at now
oh i don't even know when i woke up
guess that it's stop and shop
stop and shop kids stop it show up billy
bobby tommy johnny
charlene we're going over to stop and
shop
[ __ ] kevin's got hockey are you a
dunkin donuts person donkeys
hardcore huh what's your order at
donkeys uh right now it's just a nice
coffee with cream and sugar
i just love the cream and sugar up there
i used to get extra extra extra
it's delicious it's like ice cream i see
those it comes with a carhartt jacket
too
and a parliament because i see ben
affleck
you know when they benefit
that's how you say it with the accent
benefits yeah yeah
ben affleck i see i see ben affleck
get caught with dunkin donuts all the
time always seems like he's about to
drop it
yeah he's always struggling it looks
like the lightest sugary coffee
extra extra i like it crunchy on the
bottom oh
i used to drink it like that i'm black
now but i used to drink it like that you
are yeah
[Laughter]
shop all right stop and shop did uh did
either one of those houses
up until second grade or now have a
garage yeah the the
new the one they have now then do they
have they have now does is there a
refrigerator in that garage no
what does that mean we have a basement
fridge that's all you need these are a
fridge
fridge what's in it uh usually stuff my
dad doesn't want my mom to know he has
because he spends all his time in the
basement and he can eat
garbage c4 generally what we're talking
about bodies and batteries
yeah it's uh like fingers food uh and
soda
nice and it used to be beer but then it
got to a point where when i would come
home and i'd check it the beer was
from three years ago yeah i really don't
think anybody's drinking beer in that
house anymore but
yeah it's the overflow it's beer sodas
yeah snacks pay me a picture of this
basement though is it finished
half of it so you come down the stairs
you come down the stairs those are
finished they're carpet it's a
man cave you know he's got all of his
pictures of stuff on the walls syria
exactly just planning plotting is a big
table where he puts you know governments
that he's overthrown
uh and then he's getting we went to this
guy last week there's a tv
uh and then the other when you come down
the stairs if you make a right that's
the palace you're looking at
recessed lighting and all i think it was
that whatever that company is that uses
a pink panther
yes it's commercial whatever sure if you
make a left there's a door
they hide it but if you open the doors
okay unfinished
there is a door though yeah it's not
like you have that and then the water
heater's right there no
okay you did for a while but no so the
fridge is in there
yes the fridge is in the unfinished side
not bad oh fridge is in the unfinished
next to the tool bench is there a way
out of that basement is there a doorway
down there there's that doorway that
goes into the finished part so my dad
can have his clients
in that way oh they come in through the
man cave yeah
and what does he do where does he have
an office down there it's like a it's
like a room it's like a studio apartment
it has like
everything except you know a bathroom
and a kitchen and then his desk and then
like the living room there's not a bed
down there is there
no all right so it's not like a studio
apartment at all now
it's like an office with a couch area
with no no
no trees okay interesting okay
uh what'd you get on your sats i don't
remember come on that's a lie
13 what
my brother i know my brother got ten
more than me so i think he got a
thirteen
twenty and i think i got a thirteen ten
that's [ __ ] is that phenomenal
it is yeah it's actually some of my
friends were like i got a
fifth you're not a sportscaster or an
astronaut okay
i'll take it shout out to the department
it's a deep cut got nothing that's
raytheon quality right there
it's pretty good hmm that is 13 times
i really appreciate you guys doing that
making me feel smart like that
okay well was that when it was out of
1600 or
okay wait wait did you get a 13 out of
what was yours out of 1600
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i got a 980
you're a [ __ ]
you should worry about what do you mean
yes i don't know everybody's going to
see
the universe fantastic okay thank you hi
after there's no slouched school it's a
good thing no one has ever reacted this
way to the information we are done
people are always like hofstra we are in
private school gotta have a little cash
to get in there
was nice i had friends that grown up
went to hofstra i dropped out it was
interesting
everybody did a lot of people drive
everybody yeah
and it was like my friend's freshman
year just
were gone by junior year and i had to
like
mingle with long island in a way i don't
think i have been prepared for
but it taught me to like hey you can
dislike almost everything about a person
on the outside
so find something in them that makes
them your friend that's pretty good and
that's the life lesson for today
milk with dinner growing up growing up
yeah but that's why i know
now i won't because it was like a you
couldn't
you know get up until you finished it
and my mom
sweet woman greatest bartender ever
beautiful just want to get all the
compliments out there before i say not
the greatest cook
really a lot of like pounded thin
uh pork chops that were really dry with
milk creates like almost a paste
that's no good and i just it's not milk
now not for me
unless it's in my coffee and called
cream and
cereal now yeah yeah with milk
yeah regular milk uh meaning like two
percent
okay he's not regular two or one two or
one percent killer
i've never heard four oh whole is four
whole is now i think i just made that up
i always assumed
hole was a hundred percent but i'm done
yeah no that would probably be i don't
know what he's talking
about he doesn't know what he's doing no
he's not holding four percent
no he just made up for hole's too much
whole is not
normal holds too much goal is like crazy
it's not enough
come on have you ever put cream in your
cereal because you didn't have
uh milk what do you think yeah
and it wasn't because i didn't have milk
there was plenty of milk you just wanted
to don't get pre-diabetic using one
percent okay
you can substitute the milk in mac and
cheese if you're making it out of the
blue box which why wouldn't you
with uh bud light and it works fine just
so everybody else knows
if you find yourself in the same
situation that i did
wow now i'm coors light hey
yes sorry are they a sponsor i didn't
mean to i was
like not yet and if we did take a
macaroni and cheese sponsor it would be
velveeta because we're not [ __ ]
joking okay i just
i was commenting on the fact that you
referred to it as the blue box that's
not what everybody calls that's canadian
canadian no that's craft craft that's
trash that's what it is
the only craft in my life is mr craft i
just want to go on record that really
exciting
we will accept any and all food or
beverage sponsors please set us up
i'm really pushing for a twisted t or
coors light this is the summer of course
this red bull is delicious
[Applause]
any injuries as a kid i bro i hurt my
ankles a lot i sprained my ankles a lot
from the rhythmic dance yeah yeah
rhythmic dance yeah did you ever go down
in a competition i don't think so do
they have like trainers and [ __ ] there
um no we didn't we were at dance center
from ashland
yeah someone was like hey i uh once went
to the hospital
i could tell you what to do yeah no we
didn't uh but we weren't doing all the
flipping and stuff so it really wasn't
happening that often but i
i yeah i rolled my ankles a lot um have
you ever had to go to the hospital on
vacation
oh i don't think we didn't go on that
many vacations
right so i don't think so where would be
a nolan family vacation
if we had one i mean we probably would
have loved to be one of those cape
families that went down to cape cod
yeah that's a lot of money right there
yeah
it's very pricey but lovely yeah but
that's like i don't i'll never get there
i don't that's just in my head
that's like crazy really oh severson's
jaws i ain't going up and in the water
never
where do you vacation down uh down
florida
no jersey oh okay i live there now
but not in the part you'd go to the
sharks no no
careful these swim up rivers now anybody
saw avon
oh no no my mom openly talked
uh [ __ ] about the women who sold mary
kay yeah that was big yeah
we were friends why did they get a car i
just saw one of those pink cars it was
like a lincoln
i don't know i don't get it the pink
mary kay cars
i don't know what you got to do lincoln
yeah it was like a mk like the edge
she just looked at me like i'm a [ __ ]
jerk off today no no no no i mean like
it should be by surprise why wouldn't
they give him like a prius or something
i don't know it was like the lincoln mkx
like the suv one they got i just saw
for sure yeah all right it might have
been a homemade job i don't think
bulldogs
some people just love to use their car
to advertise sure
um have you ever worn a kiss me on irish
t-shirt probably
not ironically i wore it ironically
yeah like maybe saint patty's yeah
probably also because it was given away
given to you by a liquor company yeah i
never paid for one does it do i get some
points for that all right i never bought
one
by any chance did your family growing up
take the orange juice out of the carton
and put it into like a
a pitcher especially no i didn't think
so my grandmother used to take it out
and blend it though
i'm sorry she would take it she would
pour the orange juice into the blender
blend it and then put it in the glass
it was delicious it like aerated it yeah
i get that it's like shaking it as hard
as you possibly can
probably 50 stuff they got going on do
you ever have that
it's pretty pretty good that's that kind
of just tossing it in the blender a
little bit
no we would drink it you would just
drink it from the pitcher well she would
pour it like if she was going to make us
a glass she'd pour a glass of it into
the blender blend it up
the blender picture wasn't on the
breakfast table no okay it was as needed
yeah as needed okay yep it's pretty good
yeah
did you have one of those really long
phone cords growing up
yes in the kitchen where you can like go
into like three different rooms with
that's just like are you old i mean
nobody no
nobody has those you have a phone in
your room you're growing up
for a while no i think we had like a
portable my brother and i had our own
line wait wait but it was
one of those kids it was just the ring
it would ring differently
if they called the number that was my
brother and eyes and it would ring
it rang twice if you called our number
but it was still the same line
okay which makes no sense i don't know
how much
they can charge you for that knowing my
dad he just called and he's like i've
been a customer for a while
give me something free and they were
like here's a number that also calls
your
phone so yeah wait so like if you were
on the phone someone if it rang twice
you picked it up it's for you but your
mom couldn't then call out
right no yeah it seemed like because we
had dial up internet so that all was
still
one line two phone numbers that's that's
useless that's not as impressive as your
separate line but that's pretty cool it
was cool i guess
that's like having a bath phone as a kid
yeah like that's my like you know
but it also made a single ring put
shivers down my spine because then it
was like a teacher is calling for my mom
but a double ring was like oh it's
somebody who's a friend chill yeah
someone is chill yeah
huh those kids are into separate lines
man that was
i had a friend who had one of those
see-through phones and her own line and
i was like what are you doing
explains at all it doesn't it's what a
crazy childhood
molly ringling my sister had the clear
one she didn't have her own line but she
had to clear one in her room and i
remember being like i remember just
looking at that thing trying to study
and be like this is
[ __ ] nuts yeah it was red we should
get one for in here oh we got
the snoopy phone i forgot about that not
a bad idea oh look
first car my first car
did you drive when you were right there
yeah my first i wanna say was that i had
my brother's
old car which i think was a really
crappy
accord and then i bought
from the auto auction
i bought a honda civic with three bullet
holes
i said a kilo under the seat i feel like
the accord had one
side view mirror it didn't have the
other remember back when that was legal
when you could just have
one that was legal yeah that was legal
wait you could only i just remember on
miami vice they had this lamborghini
that
only had a rear view on the drivers but
i think before the civic i think the
civic was when i was going to college i
think i
i drove my mom's old 98
ford taurus it was the year that they
went for the oval theme and like the
headlights were over the
radio was over it sucked because it was
rounded edges
it wasn't as it wasn't as like it was
very sleek in a way that was
uncomfortable and everybody was getting
those
um head units is that what that's called
like the cd player
that they would like pop out and take
with them when they would leave their
car and because my thing was an oval we
couldn't
put a yeah so i had to do that i had
something relative i had a
chevy lumina yeah and mine was the same
so i when i took it out i had to put one
in and it was like
held in by duct tape it was a [ __ ]
time for a mess
16 year old pulling up my brother's cd
changer was in his trunk you have to put
six cds in your trunk and then you could
switch
from the yeah you thought you were you
thought you were real [ __ ] cool
kids these days pull over what does he
do uh he
works in digital ad
marketing sales one of those that's
pretty good
he just moved to chicago ah very nice
chicago
toby recently he does all right welcome
what he does all right yeah
also the best person on earth how far
are you going hockey do you play in
college
no okay he didn't he uh he was really
good he was cool
he was really good he just and i don't
want to hurt his feeling he was a little
short
and so there isn't a lot of uh you know
yeah opportunity to go be a pro athlete
when you're a little bit
short but he played hard he took a lot
of hits
yeah yeah mike child is a tough kid he's
tough yeah
has anyone in your family ever been in a
fist fight or a fight
at a sporting event oh my mom sure tried
she's mouthy she you know that's where i
get it from she's uh
she yells and she's very protective i
don't think she ever got into a fist
fight she got hit by a puck once
what yeah so that she's like
where during the game i think her knee
was she doing a handstand
is she on the ice probably charge the
field
[Laughter]
you've never run across the field for
any circumstances have you
ran onto the field no okay my mom ran
onto the field for me when i took a i
was a pitcher in softball and i took a
um drive off my mouth that's different
yes
not to fight anyone but actually she
they were trying to get an ambulance and
my mom was like i'm taking her to the
dentist
because i had braces at the time oh that
must have hurt my they were through my
lips
oh that's always though that was always
the so that would be an injury as a kid
oh that's so that happened yeah yeah got
your crooked ankles from ballet or
whatever
that's right to the face now we're
getting now we're talking yeah that was
nasty they said that if i didn't have my
braces i would have lost like six
teeth they would just got knocked out of
my mouth oh man
yeah they also said anytime in the
future ever
in for the rest of your life those teeth
might just turn black and fall out of
your face
oh my gosh that's a fun thing to find
out
hopefully it happens around halloween i
know right hopefully it happens while
i'm here
curse from a gypsy your head starts
shrinking
favorite salad dressing ranch
nice what were the pets like growing up
no none none
ever ever goldfish hermit crab nope
none pet frog no squirrel possum no
i want you to say one that i could just
say yes to really throw you for a loop
we had nothing my mom is a very clean i
mean
my childhood was like every saturday or
whatever day it was we would just
chores clean and uh didn't stick my
house is a mess
but she just didn't want a dog because
it would shed
and too much responsibility and yadda
yadda so we never had a dog i just got
my first dog
like a year and a half ago interesting
yeah did you oh you always wanted to
have one though right yeah
you want you whined about it you want to
man that's weird yeah
is it weird a little bit does everybody
have a pet
no but it's i i can imagine what it was
like as a kid wanting a pet and not
having one and then getting a pet when
you're older
yeah it's weird yeah it's like sugar
cereal if you were allowed to have sugar
cereal when you were a kid
yeah you don't really think it's a big
deal if you weren't it's like everything
to you yeah i snort lines off my dog now
i'm like you're here let's go
have you ever made your own jello shots
yes come on
i mean yeah ever ruined a surprise party
oh probably
not that i recall but it's something i
it sounds like something i would do yeah
what's in your wheelhouse yep talking
too much anything that falls under that
umbrella
i've usually done it have you ever had
goldschlager yes
oh my god oh my god i had
it there's real gold in it is that they
it tastes similar to aftershock
i've only ever had aftershocks let me
tell you which is trash after shock
get holy i got in a dog crate
i got in a dog crate at a party after
shock have the the rock sugar in it
i think so i remember i vaguely
remembered it
it's from england isn't it i don't know
or at least it's big over there what i
know
is that the only place i ever had it was
dublin drank it directly out of the
bottle
same night i drank goldschlager and uh
stood up from where i was sitting
thinking i was fine and then all of a
sudden was like
whoa and somebody was like get it
aftershock
i was like that doesn't yeah there's no
way they can no that's chemically making
that yeah they can't delay it hitting
you
that's just you thinking but i got so i
got alcohol poisoning i now know it to
be alcohol poisoning but then i just
threw up for 24 straight out
sure yeah yeah yeah so yes i've drinking
gold my dad loves
gold chocolate we always had a bottle of
it your dad's [ __ ] old he's wild
he's wild now he loves goldschlager now
he drinks vanilla vodka and orange soda
he's a sweet man just looking for flavor
this guy's [ __ ] he's an alien right
now he's trying to
keep an eye on this guy holy [ __ ] hmm
have you ever gone ghost hunting no
have you ever been called to the
information desk at a
department store or airport or sporting
event yes
for what reason um well two stories that
kind of blend into one so the the time
that i really got my name called over
the loudspeaker was i got lost at some
sort of
christmas thing that you go to where uh
there's like a train that drives through
and shows you all the lights it's like
santa's
george i remember we used to always go
there and there was a time where i went
and i lost my mom
and i was lost there so they looked for
me but the time i got in the most
trouble at a store
was at the tiles plus on route 30 in
framingham was that on rodeo drive
it was it was
oprah owns that i believe it was a tile
store on the main
a very main road with a glass front so
like you could drive by and see right
into it
and i guess i had just found out about
the concept of mooning
somebody okay i guess i didn't know what
that was but then that day i had just
found out
and so in the aisle of the tiles plus i
mooned my brother
right in front of the window and thought
that was hilarious and my mom picked me
up with my pants
still down and dragged me out to the car
and i was in trouble for two days
what was this i was probably seven
it was last year last year
[Laughter]
ever rode in a car that was being towed
oh no that sounds fun though
ever been in the front seat of a tow
truck yes
my mom got into an accident on the way
to one of my brother's hockey games she
hit a patch of black ice and rear-ended
a rabbi
and then uh yeah i wrote in the it's
always a tough combo the rabbi right in
there with you too no
he uh no
yeah it was a weird that's the day i
learned what a rabbi was i was that
young that i was like what is this and
then every time i heard it since i'm
like
you mean the guys who get rear ended by
my mom do you guys have a pool
no my best friend had an above-ground
pool
but even then i was mad at her because
it was like why couldn't you have an
in-ground
yes because thank you cooler no they're
not that's why
no they're not yes they are no the only
thing you can do in an above-ground pool
is that same
game that everybody plays dad drinks
vanilla stolen
[ __ ] orange so hey listen everybody
loves a whirlpool but it ain't it's not
going to pull it yeah it's
it's a bathtub and above ground pool is
about no it's not i like that that's the
first time we ever heard that
we have one at the foley's and they've
built a deck around it so it's kind of
better than no pool i don't know but it
is not better than an in-ground pool and
you know it
no it's like sharing a bathtub i agree
keeps the water cooler and crisper sure
it doesn't happen yeah it's always cold
even on hot days
uh what do you know about the rotisserie
chicken i know a lot about it boston
market
we used to eat a lot of boston markets
yeah do you still get them now like the
supermarket for 8.99
no but i would yeah can i ask a question
sure you have been this whole time
can i ask you a question on my podcast
about asking questions do you remember
when boston market was
like just local i don't know that it was
i don't think it was it wasn't just like
one and they bootstrapped them but
they're big in boston right he used to
be boston chicken
oh yeah i think you're right boston
chicken but i generally back when i used
to bang
i've stepped in it recently on this
because i could have sworn dunkin donuts
wasn't actually from boston but i think
it is
oh yeah but i don't know if boston
market there is at least one of these
chains that's associated with boston
that actually isn't from boss i don't
know it used to be boston chicken i know
that for a fact because i remember when
they changed
delicious they were poised to really
take over at a certain point
yeah they're better model yeah they're
like you go in there it's tough
it's a tough one oh really i haven't
been in one in a while especially in in
new york they're
i think they started once they started
putting those mini marshmallows in their
sweet potato casserole and you were just
like where are we going yeah you jumped
the [ __ ] shirt
that's not a good t-bone what do you got
the first dunkin donuts was opened in
quincy yeah i said i said that one i
know but the what about
check boston market might be non-boston
it might just be a marketing ploy
or it's from boston i mean we're not
really known for our chicken all i know
about boston i'm looking up right now
uh newton massachusetts
there was a pro skater that got
sponsored by boston market and had a
cord unlimited boston market for life
oh when i was 16 i was like damn that's
[ __ ] any time i see it for life i'm
like i'd take that
oh yeah i would take that chipotle does
that a lot with famous people when they
say i like chipotle they're like
the black one for life yeah what they
don't need it do you do any punch cards
now you're a punch card person you know
sandwiches haircuts maybe
no clearly i haven't gotten a haircut in
two and a half years
two and a half really it's not even a
trick dusting no well because what about
the
picture
no this is just it it's can't you tell
by how it is hanging off of my head
you're guys you don't know anything
sucks i'm gonna chop it all off but no
no punch cards i don't think
interesting what did you call the game
where you would knock on someone's door
and run away as a kid ding dong ditch
thank you what did you call it knock and
run
yeah ding dong ditch that's what it is
yeah ring and run maybe
what did you call the game where you
would throw a ball against the wall and
you have to race and touch the wall
before somebody
chewy oh suey it's just short for
suicide yeah we
butts up because you would get the peg
in the butt yeah yeah
that was the crucial part was the peg in
the butt yeah i always i was always
scared of that there was this one kid
who had a canon
he was just getting something out yeah
he just like to throw balls at kids
butts and i hope that guy's doing well
and has found therapy
he's not i can guarantee you that right
hmm
he's gotten good at patching his own
drywall yeah for sure
been to a petting zoo in the last five
years no
all right anyone in your family have
adult braces
oh my mom might have okay my mom might
have i might
soon really yeah you already had them i
know and then i didn't wear my retainers
you gotta go invisalign at this point i
know but i it's they are always like it
won't work yeah
do invisalign i don't know stop yelling
at me do it
for this episode's brought to you by
invisible that's why i'm pushing it i
need a testimony one of my shows was
called garbage time
i know yeah does that count i'm just you
seem like you're keeping a running tally
so i just want to give you all well i
mean we have a lot of evidence leaning
towards
this is more just uh you know this is
just for the fire this is the yeah
these are more formalities at this point
just to keep a record uh have you ever
left a bad yelp review
no okay ever met dog the bounty hunter
no but i had an uber driver once whose
whole thing was that he looked like guy
fieri
was he used to like stand on his car and
take pictures and then talk about it for
your whole uber ride would show you the
pictures of how he
dresses up in flame clothes how do you
feel about guy fieri
i i think he's a he's a he's
an acquired taste he's got a taste that
maybe doesn't necessarily align with
mine but i respect what he does there
you go
he's the [ __ ] man okay or that that's
a shorter way to say what i said
he's the man we love you big guy guy
knows his way around a fried sampler i
can tell you that
right now he does hmm very
interesting have you ever owned your own
tap for a keg
yes it was with a it was a roommate
situation so i didn't own it but there
was one in that
one yeah yeah a kegerator
what was in there okay a small keg yeah
like what beer though oh it's probably
it's probably natty yeah nice there she
is
don't try to get fancy with your
kegerator she didn't want to tell us
anything but she's showing us
everything i know katie dolan
what do you brush your teeth in the
shower i have but i don't there's
nowhere to put it
okay when you're done with it otherwise
i would i brush my teeth leave it in
there
no but i mean like when you're done
brushing your teeth you want to put your
toothbrush down and then when it grows
to put it down right but i'll do it
while i
you know sit on the toilet is your okay
what's that
that doesn't seem that his reaction was
right ears through
yeah yeah no she's she's on the right
side you condone
toilet brushing you're sitting there as
opposed to the shower brushing
yeah because it's the pudding of it down
that's what's going to leave yours next
to like the soap and the loofah that's
yeah
can't be doing that it's [ __ ] gross
can you reach your sink from your shower
uh it's a glass door
so i like it's broken it's a broken
it's an old windshield i don't think i i
don't think i could i don't think i
could that's pretty good i think
is it yeah i got two bathrooms what whoa
really and i own it wait is it you own
you're a
landowner yeah wait look i have this
second
the second i got it the second i got a
bunch of money i was like let me buy a
house
now because i don't know how this is
going to don't know how it's going to
argue yeah so i want to make sure i
owned a property so i it's a tiny condo
it's a condo one
for two two bathrooms one bedroom one
office because you can't call it a bench
if there's no window i didn't know that
and then two bathrooms
there's no window yeah it's just like a
dark
room is it one and a half baths no two
full baths uh
two full baths yeah
but one of them one of the tubs has a
leak
so it's covered in thanks for coming
back thanks for checking in mrs nolan
we have a kegerator daddy yeah from far
enough away you're like shiny and you
get up close you're like she's
disgusting
how many pillows on the bed how many
pills do you sleep with
uh i sleep with one just one under your
head yeah that's
it yeah
that's pretty classy one it is the less
pillows the classier you are
i was thinking more like solitary
confinement because i'm an animal i
sleep with nine pillows i got two
between my legs two under my thing
oh wow plug in one you should get a
number bed
yeah they should sponsor yeah
um wait wait hold on can we say that
today
yeah helix folks check out helix
what about fan do you sleep with a fan
directly on you no
air con central air central air really
it's broken the ducks don't work you
can't turn it down too many degrees
at a time or it freaks out and stops
working for three days
i mean you're last year last year it
broke during the summer of the pandemic
and uh you know dan called somebody
because
yeah and i don't call i don't like doing
like i think it's broken because then
they'll
tell me how much it's going to cost me
and that's exactly what happened and the
guy was like your air conditioning unit
is so old you need to get it replaced
and it's going to cost you
10 grand tons of money or you can spend
100
on seven pounds of freon and i was like
i'll buy the for you yeah where was the
appraisal during all that
when you were looking at the place yeah
i don't know bastards
yeah that's how they get you next thing
you try it all you gotta get a new water
heater yeah
that's why i don't buy props
i can't be dealing with the ac
maintenance it is the thing i miss the
most about renting being able to be like
come fix this
it's broken it's pretty good no problem
um do you put chips on a sandwich yes
really yeah cape cod chips on a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich
wow life-changing what the
[ __ ] that's my honestly that's my go-to
yeah with a pickle they don't have to be
pickles and a glass of milk involved
pickle on the side not in the no okay
i'm just i don't
what would be your beverage during a
meal like that a root beer
really wow straight up no diet
no diet soda i mean i could drink a diet
we've been buying uh what do they come
in 12 packs
yes for the whole pandemic of root beer
i have like a root beer a day
it's really bad it's awesome that's
right no
dana root beer i'll drink it dan's like
a uh ginger ale
loves a good ginger canada dry who
doesn't like a nice gin yeah
you gotta actually around the holidays
canada dry or seagram yeah
yeah i only drink ginger ale on a plane
the only real place i drink it's a
little guy yeah champagne but he does
milk with dinner
if you guys sit down with dinner will he
break out milk no out of respect for me
because i've asked him to please dan is
a gentleman yeah
it's grosses me out to watch a grown man
[Laughter]
it's just like i don't know but i love
him and he can do whatever he wants just
keep it
away from me that's fantastic um
i want to ask you this what's up it is
wedding season okay theoretically um
you go to a wedding close friend
what are you looking at what's in the
envelope oh how much you give
yeah don't you drop it close friend this
is not hard you're going as a couple
this got hard once i uh got famous and
people started writing articles about
how much money i make
because you're like i want to give a lot
better nobody better do that for us i
don't want to give too much
and then look like i think i'm like hey
you need this
sure close friend i'd probably
go like 500 class
that's pretty [ __ ] classy but i also
am a
a you know child of a bartender i was a
bartender for a while myself so i'm just
like look cash having cash on hands
uh-huh
it's just nice yeah that's good 500 i
mean that's fantastic that's great
it's top-notch oh yeah but if it's like
a friend of a friend that's like
you know 200. yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's 500 that's chrissy d chas
palm and terry like
okay
have you ever skied in your jeans i've
only skied once or twice
really yeah so no i don't think so
other than the home when you got like
when when when you got like your first
big contract or your first big paycheck
was there a item that you bought like a
splurge item
tv sound system it was snow boots oh my
god
the first time i allowed myself to spend
money without being like how much is it
what's the best deal
i needed snow boots and i was like oh
i'm on tv now i can buy
expensive snowboards and i still have
them
and they hurt my feet yeah they always
do would you need the snow boots for
were you going to aspen or no
sundance no it was winter time so
it was going to be cold and what were
said boots uh
i don't even know what their brand is i
want to say like sorrel
is that a brand yes that's a that is a
brand that might still a pretty
responsible like
i don't like to spend it my dad uh
no jet skis no i don't really spend my
money but
what i do is i'll like whereas another
time i would have tried to take the
subway
now i'll just take an uber sure that's
where i'm responding irresponsible that
and grubhub
that's fine that's comfortable order all
almost all of my
really what about breakfast breakfast
delivered is delicious there's an ihop
near me that delivers and i put the
pancakes in a separate part of the
you're getting
ihop
man it's not dunkin donuts i've never
gotten dunkin donuts delivered that's
worse than dunkin donuts
delicious yeah 30-minute old ihop is not
good
it's delicious you can explain dunkin
donuts like what is it no if you're
getting an
egg sandwich brought to you from dunkin
donuts delivered to your house it's
disgusting
sandwiches are phenomenal maple bacon no
they changed their eggs and now they're
gross
they did something to them they used to
be yellow and now they're like white
with yellow in the middle to make it
look like an egg but i know they're not
cracking an egg they're not mcdonald's
let me tell you something if you spotted
the difference in dunkin donuts egg
carrier uh-huh
i get garbage i go to mcdonald's and get
a
sausage egg and cheese mcgriddle with
the egg from an egg mcmuffin
and you asked that before holy [ __ ] it's
so good
i didn't know anybody else had ever done
so i swap eggs out too
yeah it's a better egg they really are
cracking the egg i've asked yeah
they have that little thing where they
cook it
man oh man ihop delivery is [ __ ]
nice yes that's crazy like when you've
been home alone
for a year you don't notice the things
you we did that a lot
like we didn't just do that i mean it's
fantastic you know what we started
getting into that was like our special
treat
we would get a cheesecake factory
delivered that's okay
and we would just get all those
appetizers all anything that's like a
popper anything that's fried with cheese
on the inside of it sign me up okay cool
i have delivered yeah there's something
about this
we know it's delicious okay do you have
to make your table sticky at home before
you eat it
can you send the rude waitress i want
the full experience yeah you have to
wait and wait and wait and then it gets
delivered and you have to wait
section is not even full what's going on
over there i used to live next to an
ihop i'm realizing now ihop has had a
big influence on my life my grandfather
died in an ihop
in an island we're an hour in you tell
us that now
well you should have said that walking
through the door driving past it and i
think he had a heart attack i should
know this and i think he stopped in to
call
like something's wrong with me and i
think he died in an ihop
let me get a short stack quick yeah
let me get the blueberry syrup
holy [ __ ] i mean katie yeah
so that's why you're ordering it reminds
you of your credit i guess so i think
it's yeah that makes sense
so now you guys are mean for making fun
of me let me get a short stack
[Laughter]
every time that door opens you're hoping
it's your grandfather holding the bag
holy [ __ ] all right i mean i don't
how are you i i have yeah i mean i got
enough i got enough to render
a verdict but uh we do have i have uh
two here from patreon um so when you
sign up for is it raining god damn
when you sign up for patreon we can give
you an umbrella to leave absolutely
that's the sweetest thing ever i got a
nice one for you
you just have umbrellas yeah yeah we got
a t-shirt for you
what yeah says ihop i love t-shirts
there's nothing on the ihop come on
i was i stopped listening cause i got
excited about it
um so i when you sign up for patreon
we'll ask your question
you get to ask a garbage question that's
a good deal um this one's from mario
how many cats is too many two
two i agree that's the number you think
above two any more than two is two
any more than two my my best friend
childhood best friend who had the above
ground pool
four cats sleepovers were tough because
cats just
run over you while you're sleeping oh
they're just like on your head they're
everywhere
unless you can smell that kitty litter
yeah oh god
they kept it in the um pantry which i
was like but this is where you keep the
food
because it was just like a little inlet
where yeah like they could put it in
keep it out of the way but it was like
the foods i just don't i and i've
i feel bad because i love dogs so much i
feel bad disliking cats i'm sure there's
like
i'm sure your cat's great i got kitty
cat i love
i bet there's cool cats but two more
than two if they outnumber you
that's a bad idea you're getting you're
going to unionize you don't want that
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] great question mario yeah and
then we got one more this is from
christian anyone in your family a known
pool shark
oh no yeah i hustled somebody once at uh
papa shot
oh at the you know the like yeah yeah
how did you hustle them i
might well it was a mess on purpose it
was at the bar i worked at
no it was at the bar sometimes
at the bar i worked out we had like a
sidebar where it was not busy and we got
this new manager who was kind of a shady
character i think he was involved in
some bad things
and we used to always get like bcbu kids
would come in so like
basket like people from the basketball
team i want to say it was harvard but
that doesn't make any sense to me either
way there was a basketball team from one
of those schools that was playing papa
shot
and i was bartending for them and the
manager came over and he was like you
want to make some money and i was like
okay he's like well let's pretend you
suck and tell them that i'll put you
know this much money on you
beating them they're all on the
basketball team but because they're on
the team they're all like
they can't they've got a nice stroke
mine looks like beer pong but i just
fire them in there and i
smoked them ripping off harvard kids i
was like oh how do you play
how do you like them apples yeah yeah
yeah boston than that yeah
jesus yeah well you're trash
wait i have one more question okay uh
before we let you get out of here
into the rain by any chance you don't
have a guinness world record
i do i actually i no longer do
but you did i did would you like to tell
the class
what your guinness world record is it is
uh most
donuts stacked in a minute blindfolded
toby wrap this up what in the motherless
[ __ ]
it's seven the record was seven it's not
even
he has to be standing it has to be
standing up i could beat that right now
it has to be standing at the end of a
minute it's very
difficult seven seven should not be a
world record they can't be frosted they
can't be glazed
so emmy nominated emmy award winner
junior olympics
no not weirdo
[Laughter]
and the guinness world record formerly
you know who took it can't even get a
good spot at the trade shows
or anything gelman from the kathy lee
well not anymore
yeah yeah i love gilman he took my
record he beat what
yeah what kind of weird [ __ ] is that
well then [ __ ]
yellman hey i didn't say it but i sign
off i'm a religious man throwing through
rest
rest in peace these guys holy [ __ ]
katie nolan is there anything you want
the folks out there to know no i'm sorry
holy [ __ ] oh god damn [ __ ] fantastic
what a [ __ ] barn burner kippy what do
you got for him uh guys as always please
make sure you
subscribe on itunes uh youtube uh
patreon and the live shows i'm at
cameron comedy on all social media
uh and follow the all you garbage pages
on instagram and twitter as well
and choose the numbers on the clips
channel oh cliff channel just got
announced too it'll be in the
description
thank you gang we love you katie that
was absolutely unbelievable katie nolan
ladies and gentlemen
thank you we'll see you next week finish
this it's empty